on travaille 15 heures par jour et tous
les mois le prix de la viande baisse un
peu plus je suis le maire nom de je
nourris en train de crever à petit feu
staff as quant à lui ya un gars qui veut
passer
il dit qu'il américain dc comics a fait
une star
bonjour bonjour tu as bull en deux
secondes give the baby à la vache
monsieur newman ou fait demander aux
gens des villages de venir poser les
vêtements mag de poser tout nu
ça sert à rien de bloquer des routes
pour frapper plus fort et chaque fois
l'on repasse les habits en plus on verse
du lait sous l'autoroute pas est ce
qu'il faut c'est si je peux à proposer
quelque chose de différent frappé les
esprits
on se sent alors on va se mettre tout nu
sur un champ tout le village tout nu si
on fait cette photo ça fera pas une
minute trente aux actualités régionales
ça sera ramaré et north dijon vous sans
charges violait les américains mettront
jamais le pied chez moi pourrait montrer
tech et quelques ouvriers sont les rend
guère fait pour vos vies je te dis et je
rien à cacher
[Musique]
monsieur balbuzard aux appareils pour
dévier village à côté
pas mal
vous y êtes vous allez venir poser avec
new bell comme vous être mon deuxième
but nous faut maintenant vous en êtes où
avec les modèles a encore des petites
résistances
bonjour je suis très contente de faire
une photo ici
les paysans c'est la pleine nature on
devrait leur interdire de vivre à la
campagne je vous dis franchement j'en ai
à cette demande
c'est bien fait pour votre coeur vous
aviez cam écoutez vous l'avez laissé
tomber balbuzard voilà s'est pas rendu
compte tout
c'est que non
un kit écrire
hakiki non
j'ai rien à cacher mois